Lucia: 好像又小了 今天是雷阵雨
Lucia: 回的来回的来又小了
Lucia: Coming back and forth, it's getting smaller.
Lucia: 唉
Lucia: Sigh.
Lucia: 哎
Katrina:  这边就会觉得已经那么慢了
Katrina: It feels like it's already so slow.
Katrina:  有点不太舒服哎
Katrina: It's a bit uncomfortable.
Lucia: 你们壁舍什么时候有点乱啊
Lucia: When does your dorm get a bit messy?
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, OK.
Katrina: 感觉就是
Katrina: It feels like...
Katrina:  可能我工作几十年
Katrina: Maybe I'll work for decades.
Katrina:  也就是为了过这样的生活吧
Katrina: Just to live this kind of life.
Katrina: 然后提前就是过了一个缩影
Katrina: And then, it's like a preview of my future life.
Katrina: 就更加知道
Katrina: It makes me understand...
Lucia: 确实
Lucia: Indeed.
Katrina: 以后自己奋斗的目标是什么
Katrina: ...what my goals are for the future.
Lucia: 确实我也想有一个这样的小院子
Lucia: Indeed, I also want to have a small courtyard like this.
Katrina: 合资方式就是大家共用
Katrina: The co-ownership method means everyone shares.
Katrina: 确定一套一个别墅大家这样住嘛
Katrina: Deciding on a villa for everyone to live in.
Katrina: 那我当时就想着
Katrina: At that time, I was thinking...
Katrina: 我高中的时候就想
Katrina: Back in high school, I thought...
Katrina: 要是能把我的好朋友
Katrina: If I could gather all my good friends...
Katrina: 全部扔在一个别墅里
Katrina: ...and put them in a villa.
Katrina: 大家一人一个房间
Katrina: Everyone having their own room.
Katrina: 动画片真的好吵
Katrina: The cartoons were really noisy.
Katrina: 但是感觉就是
Katrina: But it feels like...
Katrina: 你一直没法把这个想法落地
Katrina: You can never make this idea come true.
Katrina: 然后你没那么大资金和时间
Katrina: And you don't have enough funds or time.
Katrina: 然后就我就感觉这个活动就
Katrina: So, I feel like this event...
Katrina: 就特别像那种梦一场
Katrina: ...is like a dream, you know?
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 首先你刷到他就很坚强
Katrina: At first, when you swipe to it, it's so strong.
Katrina: 我那天早上醒来
Katrina: That morning, when I woke up...
Katrina: 就第一眼就打开小红书
Katrina: The first thing I did was open Xiaohongshu.
Katrina: 然后我就刷到这个帖子
Katrina: And then, I swiped to this post.
Katrina: 然后我就点他主页我看
Katrina: Then, I clicked on their profile to see...
Katrina: 看他有没有发别的贴子
Katrina: ...if they posted anything else.
Katrina: 其实我还是有点害怕的嗯
Katrina: Actually, I was a bit scared, hmm.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Katrina: 但是那种心态还是
Katrina: But that mindset was still...
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia:这
Lucia: This...
Katrina: 他们进组了
Katrina: They've joined the group.
Katrina: 进组了还有考研
Katrina: Joined the group and still preparing for the exam.
Katrina: 都在忙宿舍
Katrina: Everyone's busy with dorm stuff.
Katrina: 就我本来就一直在等他们一起出去玩
Katrina: I was just waiting for them to hang out together.
Katrina: 然后感觉每天都在图书馆浪费时间
Katrina: It feels like I'm wasting time in the library every day.
Katrina: 没想到是我干活就这么几个月
Katrina: I didn't expect I'd be working for just a few months.
Katrina: 我得赶紧去尝试一些新的东西
Katrina: I need to try some new things quickly.
Katrina: 感觉认识了更多的不同的人
Katrina: I feel like I've met a lot of different people.
Lucia: 对还蛮好玩的
Lucia: Yeah, it was quite fun.
Lucia: 我当时发的时候就是
Lucia: When I posted it, I was thinking...
Lucia: 就其实我也在想这个他会不会是
Lucia: I was wondering if he might...
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then...
Lucia: 然后我就想着哎呀先发一下试试
Lucia: And then I thought, "Hey, I'll just post it and see."
Lucia: 就是就是
Lucia: Like...
Lucia: 他光知道我的身高体重年龄这些
Lucia: He only knows my height, weight, age, and stuff.
Lucia: 又不能把我怎么样
Lucia: He can't do anything to me.
Lucia: 是吧所以我就发了一个
Lucia: Right? So I just posted it.
Katrina: 但是他很高我不敢来确实
Katrina: But he's really tall. I don't dare to come, indeed.
Lucia: 确实
Lucia: Indeed.
Katrina: 而且在北京不是在大连在偏远
Katrina: And it's not in Beijing, it's in a remote area of Dalian.
Lucia: 这地方可以叫北京吗
Lucia: Can this place even be called Beijing?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 虽然说我想到可能会比较比较比较远
Lucia: Although I thought it might be quite far.
Lucia: 因为他好像是什么时候给咱们
Lucia: Because he seemed to...
Lucia: 我忘记了
Lucia: I forgot.
Lucia: 好像是发过一回那个邮件还是什么
Lucia: He seemed to have sent an email or something.
Lucia: 通知的时候
Lucia: When he notified us.
Lucia: 然后不是说会在那个
Lucia: Didn't he say that...
Lucia: 就是租一个别墅然后大家在里面那个什么
Lucia: He would rent a villa and everyone would stay there?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 然后我当时就想可能不会很近因为
Lucia: At that time, I thought it might not be very close because...
Lucia: 如果很近的话就是
Lucia: If it was very close...
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia:但是其实因为
Lucia: But actually...
Lucia: 因为我对这边就不是很熟悉
Lucia: I wasn't very familiar with this area.
Lucia: 我就我在学校
Lucia: So, back when I was at school
Lucia: 时候也从来不过来这边的
Lucia: I never came over to this side
Lucia: 就除了给环影那个啥那次
Lucia: Except for that time we filmed for the environmental project
Lucia: 呃还没有
Lucia: Uh, not yet
Lucia: 所以我们当时是来就是就是拍宣传
Lucia: So, we came to shoot a promotional video
Lucia: 然后就是是他们官方的项目嘛
Lucia: It was an official project of theirs
Lucia: 但是就是因为没有开
Lucia: But it wasn't open yet
Lucia: 所以其实那些游乐设施
Lucia: So those amusement facilities
Lucia: 都还没有正式投入使用
Lucia: Weren't officially in use yet
Lucia: 就还在测试
Lucia: They were still in testing
Lucia: 但是就是就是拍你肯定要在里面取景
Lucia: But for filming, you definitely need to shoot inside
Lucia: 所以就是可以进去
Lucia: So we could go in
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah
Lucia: 我已经大概知道里面长什么样了
Lucia: I already have a rough idea of what it looks like inside
Lucia: 但只是就还没有在里面玩过而已
Lucia: But I just haven't played inside yet
Lucia: 然后所以就这地方我就没有来过
Lucia: So, I've never been to this place
Lucia: 然后我第我第一天过来那会我就
Lucia: And when I first came over, I was like
Lucia: 我靠这么远啊
Lucia: Whoa, it's so far
Lucia: 那种感觉
Lucia: That kind of feeling
Lucia: 首都过来
Lucia: Coming from the capital
Lucia: 我觉得我们在车上也待了有坐了有
Lucia: I think we were in the car for about
Lucia: 对四四十40来分钟了
Lucia: Yeah, around forty, forty minutes
Lucia: 至少有
Lucia: At least
Lucia: 这个门要关一下吗
Lucia: Should we close this door?
Lucia: 我先把伞收一下
Lucia: I'll put away the umbrella first
Lucia: hello
Lucia: Hello
Lucia: 给您一个雨中的视频
Lucia: Here's a video in the rain for you
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks
Lucia: 我去我刚给你发的语音信息
Lucia: I just sent you a voice message
Lucia: 一直都没发出来老天爷啊
Lucia: It wouldn't send, oh my god
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry